The heavyweight champion
of the world…
-When I stepped out the ring…
-The undefeated.
…I was pretty ready
to be the family man.
-The one and only…
-Tyson! What are you doing?
Time for school.
Where's your jumper?
Just enjoy it now.
Enjoy what?
What's it like
living in a busy household?
Three girls, three boys, my wife.
All frigging crazy.
Tyson retiring,
do we think it's legit?
I've gone from topping the bill
at Wembley
to picking up dog shit on a run.
Come on, shitter.
Another day
in paradise, gentlemen.
Easy, lad!
Oh, I'm such a legend, in't I?
God!
Do you feel ready
to become a dad?
I'm gonna be right there
to cut the… placenta?
No, not the placenta.
You're gonna cut
the umbilical cord.
Last time Tyson retired,
he wasn't in a good place.
Could he slip back down that road?
Bipolar, ADHD, depression.
Boxing is really the only thing
that gives me purpose.
Me and you, let's get it on!
The world's strongest man
has called out Fury
for a fight in Iceland.
-I thought you was retired.
-I am retired.
Right.
-When are you going to Iceland?
-Tomorrow.
The boys are on tour!
It's gonna be a whole journey.
Got the belts,
all the money, all the fame.
But my biggest achievement…
Dad, I love ya!
…will always be my family.
Three, two, one.
Cheese!
Why are you married
to a fat man, Paris?
'Cause he's rich.